all right Samuel Leeds I'm here in
Johannesburg South Africa and in this
video I'm going to explain to you and
show you why you don't need all that
much money to live a really good life
[Music]
last month
I ran a Discovery Day which is where a
small group of people get together and
we work out whether they would be fit
for my mentoring packages and half the
people in the room when I asked them how
much money they were wanting to earn
they said that ultimately their plan was
to be earning between 500,000 and a
million pounds per year unless you're
planning to build something with that
income or set up a charity or something
like that 10 to 15 thousand pounds per
month should do you it should cover you
chances are you probably don't need to
become a millionaire or a
multimillionaire let me explain what I
mean and give you an example and show
you why ten to fifteen thousand pounds a
month is all you need when I was on the
honeymoon
a few years ago with Amanda we decided
to go full out we went to all-inclusive
5-star Hotel in Croatia we did island
hopping we just were only only on a
honeymoon for 10 days so we just said
for these 10 days let's not look at the
price tag let me think
let's just go absolutely crazy and we
had all the food read all the drink we
didn't look at price tags and it was
great I have worked out looking back now
how we lived in those 10 days that we
could go back to the same destination
now we could live there all inclusive
food full board doing all the island
hopping we could live there forever and
our passive income would pay for us to
live there and that's not because on
that rich that's because it doesn't cost
that much
right now I'm in Johannesburg today I've
been on Safari for the day meeting lions
and yesterday I was in the spa having
massages guess what it didn't cost that
much the safari can't oh so I've just
been at am being attacked by dog right
now cut okay we're back so here's an
exercise for you I want you right now to
write down your dream lifestyle
so if money was no object how
live on a daily basis where would you
live how often would you travel where
would you go out to eat how often would
you go out to eat what gym would you
join just all the things that you could
possibly do just write them down your
dream perfect lifestyle then when you've
done that and I hope you do do that I
want you to write down next to
everything how much it would cost to
sustain that lifestyle and then just
comment that figure below so I can say
and I might be wrong but I have a
prediction and my prediction is that the
figure it would cost to cover that
lifestyle would be somewhere between ten
to fifteen thousand pounds perma why
because it doesn't cost that much to
live a really good life is this making
sense and the great news is ten to
fifteen thousand pounds a month in
income is not that difficult I mean how
many HMOs is that like a dozen or so
it's pretty straightforward it's pretty
easy and being able to cover your
desired lifestyle in passive income we
call that ultimately financially free
now it's not much difficult to do that
but first I would say become financially
free and begin becoming financially free
it's just really easy that's when your
passive income is equal to or greater
than your necessities your basic living
costs and to give you an idea how easy
that is
I did it by age 21 and last year I
helped 26 people become financially free
this year my goal is to help 50 people
become financially free if that inspired
you if that has been useful please don't
forget to subscribe and more importantly
share this video let the world know
because you really don't need that much
money if you share it on your Facebook
and I happen to see it I like it I'll
share it and I'll add you as a friend
god bless you have a wonderful day
[Music]